i would like you to rap about uh
your enjoyment of dressing up in women's
clothes
oh vladiel there's some people in our
audience today who
look quite similar to me and have the
same last name
so i'm gonna ask thomas to spotlight
those people uh and you'll all be able
to
meet my family look at this i my my dad
is there my mum is there with my sister
and her boyfriend will hello everyone
um what i wanted to do
i think i'm going to regret this so i
like doing raps where i
interview people about themselves and
then do a rap about them right
i want to interview you all about me
and then rap about that i'll come to mum
first you don't need to be all motherly
and like
oh you're such a nice boy i'm not that i
would expect you to say that
um but something about me that you want
me to rap about that that maybe would be
a
fun and exciting i can and we were
talking
i was talking about this today um
using an umbrella in the wind
i hate you so much okay so for those of
you that don't know
and i say this in my shows quite often i
have a a phobia now a phobia is an
irrational fear and it's not an
irrational fear i am scared of
not umbrellas i'm scared of the wind
right people
people say oh i hate umbrellas because
when it's windy umbrellas get they pop
poke your eyes out
i've also the wind has taken hats from
me it's taken helium balloons
let me show you what i'm actually
broadcasting from here these lights
have umbrellas on the whole way i'm
through this show i am actually wetting
myself with fear i have to face down
these two it's like
two horrible little daleks just facing
me okay so using an umbrella in the wind
i don't like it but i'll do it
um let's go let's go will i mean will
and i haven't really spent too much time
together because
we're in completely different continents
um but
tell you what it's been very sad it has
been very sad hasn't it um
well you're you're charming gentlemen
will is very brave
um will flies uh you fly helicopters
don't you for the
for the the navy her majesty's royal
navy yeah
yeah oh wow so we know which side you're
on boom megan marco
yeah the queen she's gonna send you over
to like oh would one take a heat-seeking
missile to beverly hills
because i'm going to wrap up something
that's scary for me what's the been one
of the scariest moments in your life
please don't take it too dark i don't
i've done that live before someone goes
well that would be when i had to switch
off the life support of my only child
that got a much bigger laugh than i
expected it to oh dear just ask your
sister
ask her something then come back to you
did you say yes okay
so harriet give me something about me to
rap about
oh i know
[Music]
i did kind of tell you harry i did say i
am going to get you involved with the
show
you can see who got the quick thinking
brain out of our family can't you look
at this
by the way harriet's actually a
qualified medical
you have a doctorate i don't so harriet
absolutely trashes me and everything
yep i've also had a couple of glasses of
wine
[Laughter]
i'm gonna say about going
to when you you've done a concert when
you're into your guitar
and you all wore those big hooded cloaks
and if it was a village hall somewhere
yeah
okay so for people who don't know i used
to be in a in a drone and noise band
will let's let's get yours then so i was
uh
i was once on a stag do with some men
and we were playing that game
with some men it's not a stag do with
women is it well that's not how it works
sorry it's not a real stag to if women
are there
we're playing that silly game uh called
save the queen
where you put a coin in someone's glass
and then you have to drink all of your
beer
and i swallowed the 50 pence piece
um and it got stuck in my throat and
that was that was really scary
because you had disrespected the monarch
right that's why yeah
papa papa smurf you're on your own there
um
what what what do you want me to rap
about do with me i would like you to rap
about
your enjoyment of dressing up in women's
clothes
oh vladiel okay so when i was 18 my
mother made a photo album of all the
times i've dressed up uh
in women's clothing and you might think
oh that's four pictures no it was one
for every year
it was and look right when i was two i
didn't have a choice as to what clothes
i wore so that's your fault for putting
me in little dresses
harriet got all my hand-me-downs okay my
enjoyment dressing up in women's
clothing
uh brilliant okay cool so using an
umbrella in the wind going to a
i used to play music wearing big black
cloaks uh
will will story because we don't really
know each other well enough to have
shared experiences yet but the time he
choked on 50
piece and the enjoyment of dressing up
in women's clothing that i very clearly
have and
continue to this day i'm not standing up
but it is a skirt trust me
okay let's uh do this start with the
will
spill the beans cause i asked you you
are out there lads on the stag too
no ladies making lots of noise getting
rowdy
chilling with your boys you're there in
the pub and you're feeling kind of mean
kind of squiffy i'll be like save the
queen put that little penny there and
i'm glad you asked a 50 pence piece in
the bottom of your glass
you were like oh no [ __ ] there got her
down this pint of bitter
maybe ale maybe pilsner save the queen
before it drowns and it kills up
otherwise that's called treason so you
neck it down drink the pint that reason
but it gets stuck in your throat
that's a lot all it's like the mouth of
a bottle i be calling epiglottal that's
the tiny little flapper skin covering
esophagus
let me move on here got a lot of this
i'll be imploding
expanding if i'm in the wind then you
know my hands in free
maybe wear a glove never got a covering
to save me from above when the rain
comes down
that's hesitation i never want to
protect myself from precipitation why
cause umbrellas i'm a very scared fella
feeling pretty worried if i see that
weather coming down with the clouds and
i try them
more stormy and wet than poseidon or
neptune in the wet room they're in a spa
get an umbrella i'll leave it there in
the car keep it firmly grip when i hold
them my least favorite ones they're from
the golf
course why cause the radius is much
bigger than the whole height of a kid
like three years old people ask me why
i'm worried it might get
taken to the sky poke out my eye yeah i
be dropping in
really scared about mary poppins cause
she floats around there with the thing
here we go yeah everybody trying to sing
but not me i play guitar i'm gonna roll
up there with my nice paparis like chris
yeah go and have good luck getting to
the pub yeah you can get the thumbs up
from the crowd but nobody attended
or those big cloaks i'm offended if you
ain't listening to the little tunes that
i spit
down tune there start that mosh pete
wearing that cloak like a wizard i said
mosh pete like feeling kind of whiskier
you know pete when you're smoking there
in the highland get it up north is the
best part of the island
i be going up there why because they
like women's clothing see all of the
kilts that they got they'd be showing
her undercarriage i'll be getting up in
inverness when i was married that's a
true fact city i was wet
dressing in the clothing bra on my head
brah on my neck can i do it at the back
got long arms i can reach that clasp
everybody wants to look under there i'm
like yeah so what frilly underwear i'll
be showing
i'll be shimmying right side to side
everybody looks at pictures provide
that was yours i borrowed it from your
drawer put it on there like one to four
i be giving myself 10 out of 10 i like
wearing the clothes made for women
people say you look cute when you're
wearing the suit but actually it's nicer
when i'm like ooh
there on the beach everybody see me got
a nice felt figure in my bikini
that's that very good
wow that was fun wasn't it and only a
tiny bit embarrassing
um i was trying to find the picture of
you an address on my phone where i was
too slow oh what a shame what are saying
well you're getting kicked out of this
show there we go
thank you a very much family for that